Continental Tire coaches corner we bring
in the Sixers head coach Brett Brown as
they pick up the victory last night they
put aside the Brooklyn Nets how do you
feel today coach I mean it's always a
relief to get through a series sort of
getting ready to pay more attention now
to Toronto but it's a it's always a good
day to wake up after you after you've
closed out a series what happens when
you go home after a game like that like
are you are you up all night yup for
sure it's not anything you know you get
out of your car and it was a late game
last night it was an eight o'clock game
so you're really not home till midnight
and you know you stay up and watch a
little bit of the game you know look at
Toronto a little bit but for me it's
never a situation where you were able to
go to sleep quickly did you see the
Lillard shot that closed down Oklahoma
City incredible do you coach that is
that like strategy wise what do you
think Terry Stotts said he reminded me
of Jimmy Butler for us head to to game
winners and it's funny it was the same
sort of vicinity Damien's was probably 2
maybe 3 feet for the row but if you pay
attention to their footwork you know
it's sort of a side dribble to it to
your right he plants his right foot
which a lot of times for right-handed
shooters you know they'll play off the
dominant pivot foot their left foot and
so like I put my coaching hat on and I'm
looking at you know just the technique
of how he got a shot off the the
breathtaking thing for all of us is the
distance that he shot it from but the
technique that he got a shot off you can
see why you know arguably maybe the
league's best defensive player and Paul
George was caught off guard but that's a
that's a heck of a way to close out a
series but coach I'm not sure in today's
NBA of of what is allowable that that
you just it's sort of common if I said
20 years ago guys are going to be taking
thirty seven footers you'd say maybe
desperation heave or they wouldn't be
out there very long
now all of a sudden you know how much
strategy goes into how deep these guys
are shooting threes or defending how
deep they're shooting um there's a lot
of strategy you know there dad that is
an outlier what you saw but for instance
if you were to game plan against the
Golden State Warriors will I call it a
pick up one you know what's the pick up
point of the ball and really
historically to your point the large
majority the lead you pick up points are
probably the three-point line maybe a
step out but when you start getting into
like James Harden stuff and Steph Curry
stuff Damian Lillard stuff you pick up
points change you know you really as you
cross half-court you have to be aware
you know we just got done a series with
with Brooklyn and people like D'Angelo
Russell as an example you better be on
high alert the second the ball passes
half-court
the league is clearly changing you know
the three-point shot is become King and
to your point the distance with which
some of these players can shoot it is is
part and parcel now all of our game is
brett brown the 76ers head coach joining
us Dan Patrick show you came into the
postseason with only 10 games with this
starting unit of embiid Simmons Butler
Harris and Redick you're still getting
to know this team and they're getting to
know one another how difficult is that
been it's difficult only in the sense
that you feel that completely from where
I said like the subtle nuances that that
players who have a history with each
other or you know a full like season you
can see the subtleties of familiarity
and for me on the fly as the coach to be
able to say you know something a word a
phrase or reference something out of
context you don't have that backdrop you
don't have that background and I think
that that because that group that you
just spoke of is talented you know you
can cover some stuff
I'm always mindful and to a point
fearful of like when it really matters
when it gets down to you know crunch
time you're not going to have the
context and so my belief and I've said
it publicly and I'll say it to you when
we came into the playoffs was like how
do you just land the plane keep the
spirit keep the health grow their form
and buy time and this is what we have
been able to do with Joelle's health and
getting some wins and getting through
Brooklyn now we have a Toronto series
and it's it's a very unusual sort of
accumulation of history or lack thereof
that we do have with a group but you
know as I said I we got some talent now
we just try to move this ship forward
and buy some time and keep trying to
find ways to win got a little chippy in
this series your guys certainly like to
talk in bead certainly likes to do you
embrace that attitude it's not my style
it's you know I think the spirit of
Joelle as an example is is he takes it
right to the line I don't feel like he
crosses the line I think at some point
you know it's who he is it's how he
plays it's how he gets himself motivated
and it's true he is young and we get a
bunch of young guys on our team but it's
something that you know you're always
trying to respect the game you're always
trying to keep boys at the forefront and
try to help grow these young players and
at times you know there's a spirit about
I mean a lot of great players we've all
seen is a maverick and many of them and
how that how that is displayed comes out
in different ways but to to Joelle's
situation to to reference Joelle I think
he just plays with a tremendous spirit
personality and that's that's kind of
who he is I don't know if you knew this
but it was Pryce six weeks ago that
Reggie Miller said that
he would love for Ben Simmons to reach
out to him and that he would help him in
the offseason learn to shoot threes did
you know that I did not know that I did
not know that I mean I speak I speak to
Reggie often because we bump into each
other lately with the TV with the TV
situations would pregame my interviews
he's um I mean he said he's an
incredible shooter for sure and I think
the Ben Simmons shot you know if you
look at his free-throw let you start
maybe a little bit closer I believe it's
improving you know it's the input in
time all the time and we've seen him
with Yanis you know like the three-point
shot as we spoke about earlier it's such
a dominant part of us for nowadays and
like you on us you know if Ben can get
that and I believe you will I think
everybody forgets Danny's 22 years old
and it's really under the microscope at
times maybe a little bit more than I
think it should be but when he can grow
that part of his game he really does
become borderline unguardable have fun
in the next series play nice and
congratulations coach we appreciate your
time yeah thanks for having me Dan
that's Brett Brown 76ers head coach
choosing his words carefully with Ben
Simmons and his jump shot Continental
Tire coaches corner content I are proud
to be the exclusive tire of the Dan
Patrick show no matter where you drive
what you drive or how you drive
continental designs tires for what you
do for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app